cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now from los angeles for
more on this
david actually let me start there with
the students we hear that new guidance
what about vaccinations for kids under
12. are we expecting that anytime soon
we certainly hope so you know the trial
is ongoing now at a lower dose than
adults got and it looks excellent it's
protecting we're getting very high
levels of immunity
and it's remarkably safe so my hope is
that potentially by the end of the
summer it could be filed at the fda
and starting to vaccinate kids in
september obviously
every parent wants that to happen as
soon as possible if they're going to
vaccinate their child
david it's wildly different in different
states
the vaccination rates right now vermont
for example is around 80 percent
um alabama's closer to 40 with
discrepancies like that how does that
impact places where masks are still
required
everywhere for everyone like airports
what should we be doing
well i mean we have two countries right
we have the vaccinated and the
unvaccinated only half
of our citizens in this country have two
shots and you need two shots to be
protected from delta
so because we're not requiring a vaccine
passport that is a validation that you
have a vaccine we're still and we should
require
mass at airports at all public places on
planes
places you can get indoor and
potentially spread this virus this new
delta virus
is dramatically more infectious than all
the previous variants
and with that in mind dr aegis the delta
variant being sort of like the big
question mark for so many of us should
we be looking at a shot that
specifically targets
that variant so
the the original variant is what the i
mean the original virus is what the
vaccines were designed to and it changed
over time and that's what the variants
are
so our current immune responses clearly
protect against the delta
there's a trial that's beginning shortly
with a delta specific variant but right
now it's not needed
and i don't think it will be needed but
we have to be on our toes and it's
basically a dress rehearsal
in case of variant comes that doesn't
respond at all to the vaccine
it's not been identified around the
world yet but it's a potential
doctor how susceptible are people who
have already had covid
to the delta variant
they are susceptible that's the problem
is that when you get covered
much of your immune response is not
neutralizing not to that spike protein
and with delta you need a really
significant
a neutralizing antibody and t cells and
so you need to get the vaccine
if you prior hackover to be protected
from the delta variant
you really do okay dr david agus thank
you very much